what does a brazen law students with
pink accessories a cheerleading squad
captain and an exchange student from
Africa have in common in addition to
being strong female characters on the
big screen they are the epitome of our
mm I'll dude follow us while we get into
the nitty gritty details on our favorite
chick flicks from the 2000s you'll laugh
you'll cry you'll cringe at the frosted
tips and choker necklaces but most
importantly you'll be transported back
to a similar time when we all had to
worry about what was making Chad Michael
Murray fall in love with us if the
phrase never judge a book by its cover
was represented visually it would be elf
woods and Legally Blonde when we first
meet Elle she exudes perfection she's
the head of her sorority dating the
governor's son and is a beauty icon Elle
seems to have it all going on until her
boyfriend breaks up with her ahead of
his acceptance to law school fearful
about how his association with her will
affect his image in classic kick-ass
woman fashion Elle gets into law school
and proves that beauty and brains can
and does exist ultimately earning her a
spot at class valedictorian Legally
Blonde
is a classic feminist anthem for women
feeling trapped in the confines of
femininity and expectations of society
study what you want in school wear and
enjoy makeup let go of the boys who
don't see your worth but if I'm gonna be
a partner in a law firm by the time I'm
30 I need a boyfriend who's not such a
complete bonehead Parent Trap is a
wholesome reminder of the importance of
people we call family in our lives when
Haley and annie lindsay lohan times to
unintentionally run into each other at
summer camp they are immediate enemies
without knowing they're biologically
twins although they quite literally look
like the same person they seek out
social destruction of one another
through various pranks at camp
over time they come to know each other
and realize they can use each other to
their own benefit to meet their
biological parents each twin gets to
build a relationship with a parent they
never knew all while scheming to get
them back together a little
dysfunctional but heartful at the same
time I made the mistake of not coming
after you
Lissie I'm not gonna do that again no
matter how brave you are
cheerleaders rivalries and big red oh my
bring it on
not only transports us back to the
similar times of high school but also
brings with it an important life lesson
self-esteem faced with outside
influences from friends and foes on how
to run the squad Torrance Shipman
Kirsten Dunst learns to think for
herself and trust in her sense of
direction her morality and confidence is
built up when she swaps out toxic
friends for support of allies takes
responsibility for big red stealin the
clovers tears and Tunes out the social
pressures of a perfect tiered program
and replaces it with a creative and
unique routine a cult classic Mean Girls
was instrumental in showing us the dark
side of popularity Katy herons character
is a shining example of the pressure
girls face to confirm upon entering high
school to dress a certain way hang out
with particular people even eat the
right food when everything crumbles
around Katy and she isn't able to
recognize herself in the mirror she
realizes there is more to life than
being popular why is everybody stressing
over this thing I mean it's just plastic
Hilary Duff as Lizzie McGuire was our
spirit animal with all her clumsiness
and good intentions big dreams and
supportive friends she took us to Rome
on this classic flick after running into
a pop star with a problem
Lizzie agrees to be his co singer in a
huge concert having to face her fears
and being on stage in front of people
after a public spill left her ego soar
Lizzie learns to stand on her own two
feet and move forward with strength and
confidence
that's what dreams are made of if you
say you didn't have a crush on Chad
Michael Murray you're lying to yourself
in this modern spin on the classic a
Cinderella story uses flip bones and
emails to connect Hilary Duff with her
prints aside from all the known
characters like the wicked stepsisters
and fairy godmother we get to see a more
honest and vulnerable side to the prince
he doesn't like football and he craves a
loving and intimate connection over mass
popularity
I know that guy that sent those emails
somewhere down inside of you at its core
what a girl wants is a preteen anthem of
be yourself as we grow up with various
outside influences like friends schools
and even our parents we're told to act
in certain ways sometimes the people we
love and trust most deny our identity
and free will after meeting her royal
father for the first time Daphne
Reynolds is quickly pushed into the mold
of presenting herself as royalty the
problem she's the farthest from it after
a falling out her father comes to
realize that Daphne's quirks and flares
like falling on the catwalk during a
fashion show for all things that make
her unique and are important to
celebrate not hide I wouldn't I wouldn't
change her I wouldn't change anything
about y'all and change one hair on your
head moms just don't understand us am i
right well not exactly as a teen our
mothers are often seen as an authority
rather than a friend which can keep this
important relationship at arm's length
when anna lindsay lohan's and her mother
test Jamie Lee Curtis end up swapping
bodies in a freaky occurrence allowing
them to get to know each other a lot
better than they could have ever
imagined what we love most about Freaky
Friday is a reminder to not take your
mom for granted to get to know her as a
human being and to be here honest and
authentic self with her in return
thank you
[Music]
amanda bynes was on a roll in the 2000s
with movies centered around being true
yourself pretending to be her twin
brother and escaped the mounting
pressure to confirm to her mother's idea
Foreman inity viola puts on a wig and
joins the soccer team under her
brother's name at a new school
throughout the journey is not only viola
who learns about the importance of being
authentic but also her new friend and
secret crush channing tatum both
characters learn how to be vulnerable
and honest with each other about
themselves and we see them strip away
somewhat literally the identities that
they hide behind at the final soccer
match I just wanted to prove that I was
good enough ah I guess the 2000s a time
of Guitar Hero and makeovers in movies
to make the perceived unhappy male
character well hot we've luckily moved
past this trope in movies mostly Fidan
Hathaway as Mia Thermopolis in The
Princess Diaries played the part well
mostly in part to her spot-on
angsty teen acting she made it clear to
the female audience that the lines of
the manatee are blurred you can care
about the dolphins and enjoy getting a
mani-pedi you can rule a country and
write in your diary femininity comes in
all packages and we are free to express
that in any way we want
just because I'm royal doesn't mean I'm
any different I mean come on I'm really
the same person this 2006 flick made us
believers in karma and sisterhood when
John Tucker revealed to have several
girlfriends at the same time the girls
band together to teach him a lesson
cue Britney snow the undercover spy
intended to make John Tucker
fall in love so that he can be crushed a
little harsh
but we get the sentiment be honest and
genuine in your actions or face a bumpy
fate or at least some cake in the face
listen I deserve this less gaming to
murder than John Tucker Must Die but
equally important and sharing the
message of friendship Sisterhood of the
Traveling Pants was a key player in our
realization of the importance behind
building strong friendships when four
friends are separated over a summer and
without easy access to the online world
that we now have they opted to keep in
contact by sharing a pair of magical
pants each young woman takes turns
wearing them and experiencing new things
before shipping them to another part of
the
with the message to their next pal
nothing like shared experiences and
confiding in one another to build a
lasting relationship the real magic of
the pants was in bearing witness to all
of this this fine coming of age classic
reminds us that if were in a rush to
grow up we will miss life happening
right in front of us
Jenna rink wants nothing more than to be
30 the only problem she's 13 after a
magical birthday wish transports her to
her future self at 30 she discovers that
everything she had hoped for as a teen
has come true
everything but a meaningful love after
backtracking her missteps she comes to
find that love was right in front of her
the whole time the lesson take life one
day at a time and be grateful for what
you do have in the present moment
[Music]
why go through life unnoticed
is the main takeaway of this 2006 flick
featuring Jo Jo when two friends are
being pulled apart by a move they wish
for a miracle and a mermaid appears if
only it were that easy in real life they
must help her to find love in order to
gain a wish in their adventures the
girls learn valuable lessons of
self-expression and being yourself also
that friendship can extend beyond
borders and shorelines who says the math
we learn in school doesn't translate to
the real world KC Carlyle Michelle
Trachtenberg proved this theory wrong by
using her love of math to Land's triple
jumps and skate her way to the top
feeling down about being an outsider in
high school she finds ice skating and
learns to be confident in herself and
her abilities a tale of perseverance and
hard work for all young gals ice
princess reminds us to follow our
passions and interests no matter what
the opinion of others maybe this life is
a highway in this iconic Britney flick
when three friends reunite after
graduation they decide to travel across
the country to rekindle their friendship
along the way they share their fears of
moving on from school and dealing with
being somewhere in between an adult and
a child or as famously sang by Britney
Spears not a girl not yet a woman this
is something we all were on the cusp of
feeling when this movie came out and it
helped us to put things into perspective
has any idea where life's gonna take us
guys what we have is now Allie and Noah
were for sure the pinnacle relationship
and all of our fantasies in the early
2000s their fire burning love intensity
and obsession with one another was all
we wanted of course until we realized
that this sort of behavior doesn't mean
everlasting love which paralleled their
breakup in the movie as they grow older
and independently from one another they
realized that unconditional love is
truly the foundation for a lifelong
healthy relationship of course I scream
kisses and date nights at the movies are
also part of this you wanna dance with
me what lessons does life-size teach us
other than be careful what you wish for
or conjure up to start communication
casey lindsay lohan and her father are
still reeling from the death of her
mother which has torn them apart enter
Eve Tyra Banks a magical doll who has
unintentionally come to life while many
of her encounters in the real world are
silly Eve is really present to help
everyone become better versions of
themselves and ultimately communicate
their pain and hurts in order to
strengthen bonds in this small size film
the lessons are life-sized share is your
typical high school girl she is
mega-wealthy has a digital system that
picks out her outfits for her
this was the 90s remember and has the
maturity of a 32 year old okay maybe not
that common but one thing we love about
cher Horowitz is her empathy she reminds
us not to judge a book by its cover and
promotes a healthy lifestyle
she also coins the excelled phrase that
surely will be in history textbooks and
with that nostalgic walk down memory
lane we are reminded by the defining
women on the screen that we strive to be
in the 2000s although we've grown up
there is still something wonderful about
being able to dip back into our
childhood to be reminded of how far
we've come
don't forget to subscribe to the things
and we'll see you in the next video
you